Hey folks, we have some super exciting
news at the Four Boxes Diner. Of course,
it's been a crazy week and you know,
keeping up with all my Four Boxes Diner
videos, my Fox News appearances and all
my commitments there and given the
amazing amounts of news involving, you
know, Attorney General Pam Bonnie,
Donald Trump, the war in Iran, the
Supreme Court, birthright citizenship,
and the like. A crazy week. With that
said, something very exciting occurred
just yesterday, late afternoon, early
evening. President Donald J. Trump
actually went so far as to post on his
Truth Social website an interview that I
did, the entire interview in fact, uh
that I gave to the Fox News Channel. So,
I was incredibly grateful and pleased to
find out that the leader of the free
world had done so. A fan reached out to
me to let me know, "Hey, Mark, you're
not going to believe this, but check it
out. President Donald Trump posted this
on Truth Joe just a few minutes ago."
So, of course, that was extremely
exciting news to find out that the
president had noticed my work,
recognized my work, and actually went so
far as to post it for all of his
millions and millions of followers over
there on True Social. I'm incredibly
grateful, and of course, it reminds me
to thank you, all the fans, and all the
supporters of the Forboxes Diner uh
channel here on YouTube and on Rumble
and my work over there on X4boxes Diner.
Uh, you know, I'm incredibly grateful
that not just the president of the
United States watches my work and and
does things with it, but I'm also
grateful that all of you do as well. And
that's why I'm grateful and thank you
every day basically for being the top
voice of the Second Amendment. Thanks to
not just the 2025 Gundies Awards, but
the 2026 Gundy's Awards, which of course
none of which would have been possible
without the support of you, the viewers,
and the people that you know learn from
and share and watch uh this channel. So
again, I just wanted to share this sort
of incredible moment of President Trump
uh sharing my constitutional work on his
social media account over there at Truth
Social. And again, I want to use this as
an opportunity to extend my huge thanks
not just to the president of the United
States, but also to all of you who've
been supporting me, engaging with me,
and sharing my four box of diner videos
and my appearances on Fox News, as well
as my various constitutional lectures I
give throughout the year. So again, it's
kind of these these types of
acknowledgements and and recognition and
support that, you know, keep me going
late at night and early in the mornings
as I get through another 150 page
opinion by some judge uh that screwed up
the Second Amendment, Six Ways to
Sunday. But we got to keep on going
because we're all in a fight for
America. America has a lot of enemies
out there. But I still believe that the
trend is our friend and we can prevail
for America if we keep right on
fighting. and I certainly intend to keep
on fighting uh here and everywhere I can
uh for the good of the United States of
America. Okay, so with that said, I'm
going to play for you now the interview
that President Trump uh posted on his
truth social account. Several of you or
many of you have probably already seen
this uh but for the sense of
completeness or the for the sake of
completeness, I'm going to play it for
you here again in case you're
interested. So again, thank you again
for tuning in to the four boxes and I
will see you again real soon. And here
is my interview on the Fox News channel
that President Donald Trump felt it was
appropriate to post on his account.
Check it out. The United States Supreme
Court is set to hear arguments this week
in a major case on birthright
citizenship. Some Trump cabinet members
are expected to be in the courtroom on
Wednesday as justice weigh who can be
granted citizen citizenship under the
Constitution. If you're born here, are
you automatically a citizen? It's one of
the highest profile cases of this term.
Let's bring in Mark Smith, a
constitutional attorney and a member of
the Supreme Court bar. Are you making
any predictions, Mark, about how the
Supreme Court will will see this case
and rule on it?
I think there's an excellent chance this
is going to be the vict v biggest
biggest victory of Donald Trump's career
as a politician frankly to actually fix
a constitutional wrong that has been a
wrong for over a hundred years largely
because no one has had standing to sue
over it until Donald Trump's brilliant
move to enact this executive order which
finally finally gave rise to the
opportunity to get this issue before the
US Supreme Court. Up until that time,
people did not have standing to sue
because the only people that sort of got
directly impacted by this, if you're
born in the America, you're
automatically American citizen. They
were beneficiaries. So, they obviously
were not going to sue over this. And
now, because of Donald Trump, we're in
front of the Supreme Court and hopefully
we're going to get a good outcome in
favor of the Constitution. Tom Dri was
on Fox News Sunday earlier today. He had
this to say about how he sees the case.
Listen.
Perthright citizenship, like it or not,
is enshrined in the constitution. So, I
do think that the administration is
going to have a bit of an uphill battle.
But I will say this, having read the
briefs, looked at what the
administration is arguing, they have
presented a much stronger, more
compelling argument against birthright
citizenship than I had thought coming
into this. I don't know that it's going
to be enough to get five votes in their
favor, but they've made it a close case.
Wasn't birthright citizenship originally
uh supposed to help those who were
slaves or children of slaves be
recognized as US citizens?
>> That's right, John. The reality is that
after the Civil War, the United States
adopted the 14th Amendment. In the 14th
Amendment's text, literally in the text,
John, there's two components that have
to be satisfied for you to be a citizen.
The first is yes, you have to be born in
the United States, physically born in
the United States. That's step one. But
that's not the only step. You also have
to be what's known as subject to the
jurisdiction thereof. That is the text
of the 14th amendment that the left in
America likes to pretend is nothing more
than a ink block. But the reality is
that subject to the jurisdiction
thereof, John, is very important because
what it says is if you're born, you have
to be born in the United States and you
have to be loyal to the United States,
which means you're not loyal to a
foreign power. Now, if you're the child
of illegal aliens, or if your parents
bring you here on a holiday and you're
born here while your parents intend to
go back to China, let's say, you're not
loyal to the United States as understood
by the law. You're beholden to another
foreign country. And that is going way
all the way back, which by the way is
why Native Americans were not citizens
under the 14th amendment. It required a
change in the statutory law in the 20th
century, John, to make Native Americans
uh lawful US citizens because although
they were in the United States at the
time of the uh 1868 14th amendment, they
were not loyal to the United States
because they were loyal to their
respective tribes. Jonathan Turley is a
Fox News contributor, also George
Washington University law professor.
Here's how he sees the argument.
When the 14th amendment was drafted,
some of the drafters said explicitly
that it does not allow for birthright
citizenship. The problem are these six
words, this clause put in the middle of
an otherwise clear sentence. But the key
is that those words were not in that
sentence in the original draft. They
were intentionally inserted. So you
can't just treat them as superfluous.
They were inserted for a reason. And I
think that there are compelling
arguments on both sides here.
So, he seems to say that the the
drafters of the 14th Amendment made it
pretty clear.
>> Well, I think it's even clearer that in
favor of Donald Trump because in 1866,
John, there was something called the
Civil Rights Act passed by Congress. In
it, it says to be a US citizen, you have
to be born in the United States and you
cannot be beholden to a foreign power.
After that law was passed, Congress
realized that another Congress could
come down the pike and change the law.
basically making African-American,
former African-American slaves no longer
citizens. So to make sure that did not
happen, they decided to take that Civil
Rights Act of 1866 and enshrined it in
the Constitution. And that is what the
14th Amendment became, which is why the
phrase subject to the jurisdiction
thereof is essentially embraced or comes
out of that civil rights act of 1866
that literally says you cannot be
subject to a foreign power. It all turns
on are you and your parents loyal to the
United States? And if you're just
passing through on the way to Hawaii for
fun or you're broke into the country
illegally, that does not make you loyal
to the United States and therefore
you're not subject to the jurisdiction
of the United States and thus you're not
a citizen under the text of the 14th
Amendment. And I think that's what the
Supreme Court is going to say. And the
only reason, John, that we haven't said
it before is because there's never been
an opportunity to get in front of the
courts because no one had standing to
raise these kinds of arguments until
now. Jonathan Turley says that virtually
no nation in Europe allows birthright
citizenship. Are you aware of any
country in the world that does aside
from ours?
No, of course not. Look, the most
valuable asset on the planet, period, is
becoming a United States citizen. You'll
get to be a citizen of the greatest
country that has ever existed in
mankind's history. Right? That's the
reality of it. So to think that you
would hand these out just because you
happen to be born here because your
parents broke into the country is simply
absurd. You know, US citizenship is a
lot more than just taking free candy at
the doctor's office. It requires a lot
more than that. Specifically, it
requires loyalty to the country. This is
your home and it can't just be that your
parents are passing through illegally or
otherwise and you happen to get born
here. Uh that is simply not enough to
give you US citizenship. And the text of
the 14th amendment sort of proves that
out as does the history. We'll see what
the Supreme Court decides. It's going to
be a fascinating week and a fascinating
term. Mark Smith, thank you.
>> Orders up. Table 2 A.